[Musique]
lors d'observations et le procès verbal
et donc si je n'en vois points adoptées
sur les sous les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues se renouvelle pour chacune et
chacun d'entre vous mes meilleurs voeux
pour cette année qui commence aussi à
vous remercier tous ceux que vous m'avez
adressées qui sont en cours de lecture
mais qui sont nombreux et et chaleureux
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance et retransmis sur public
sénat bien sûr sont des sites et au nom
du cdh 1 comme à l'accoutumée on prend
des résolutions pour 2019
le temps des voeux c'est que le soyons
essentiel jaillir attaché aux valeurs
essentielles du sénat le respect des uns
et des autres et naturellement de
respect du temps de parole qui est
peut-être plus prosaïque mais aussi
important la parole est au président
jean marc gabouty pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole monsieur le
président merci monsieur le président
monsieur premier ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
premier ministre l'année 2018 aurait été
marquée par l'irruption des gilets
jaunes mouvement social inédit au départ
spontané et qui témoigne d'un profond
malaise notre société qu'elles soient
légitimes et généreuse souvent
contradictoires aux réalistes et parfois
provocatrices les revendications
exprimées doivent être écoutés
toutefois elle ne sera en aucun cas
justifier le déferlement de violence de
menaces d'invectivés et de dégradations
qu'a subi notre pays depuis mi novembre
le bilan humain dramatique de dix morts
et de plus de 2500 blessés devraient un
peu plus interrogées les acteurs de ce
mouvement et ceux qui l'ont soutenu avec
parfois un objectif malsain de
récupération je tiens ici au nom du
groupe rdse a renouvelé tous nos
remerciements et notre soutien aux
forces de l'ordre aux personnels de
santé et aux services d'urgences
fortement sollicités pendant cette
période
sur le plan économique et social cet
épisode a flétri l'image donc
l'attractivité de notre pays et était
destructeur d'activité et d'emploi
au-delà des mesures très significative
10 milliards d'euros que vous avez
annoncé qu'ils ont été votés courant
décembre par l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat le débat national engagé
avant-hier va s'enrichir de propositions
concernant en particulier la démocratie
de proximité les services publics et la
fiscalité et le pouvoir d'achat
ce grand débat va susciter beaucoup
d'espoir il ne faudra pas décevoir à
côté de réformes structurelles plus
longue à mettre en place des mesures
concrètes d'application immédiate seront
attendus par nos concitoyens
comment visible envisagez-vous d'y
répondre
dans quels domaines possibles et avec
quel calendrier et pensez vous associer
le parlement particulier le sénat
représentant des territoires à
l'élaboration de ces mesures et de ses
réformes en amont d'un examen
strictement législatives des projets de
loi je vous remercie pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre en charge des
relations avec le parlement monsieur
marc feydeau
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur gabouty devant vous remercier
de votre question qui permet d'en de ces
questions au gouvernement de porter un
certain nombre d'éclairages vous me
posez la question de l'association
finalement des parlementaires et
singulièrement du sénat au grand débat
national qui va s'ouvrir
vous avez raison de dire d'abord je
crois qu'il peut susciter il va sans
doute susciter un certain un grand
espoir pour un certain nombre de gens
qui cherchent des solutions qui pose un
certain nombre de questions et de
problèmes et auquel il va falloir
répondre
peut-être vous répondre en trois temps
le premier temps c'est le temps du débat
qui est en train de s'ouvrir j'aurais
salué l'initiative d'un certain nombre
de parlementaires au sénat et à
l'assemblée nationale
deux responsables de groupes qui ont dit
qu'il s'associerait au débat avec les
divergences qui sont à l'intérieur de ce
débat pour faire en sorte que les
français puissent se saisir des
questions qui leur sont soumises et se
saisir peut-être pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux d'autres questions et pour
faire en sorte que les parlementaires
puissent aussi être les témoins vigilant
et les porte parole d'une certaine façon
de ce qui va se dire ici la deuxième
chose dire aussi que le premier ministre
adressée aux présidents des deux
assemblées un courrier
pour créer un comité de suivi permettra
chaque groupe politique puisqu'il s'agit
bien d'affaires politiques de pouvoir
suivre les débats et s'approprier
également le débat la troisième chose et
c'était peut-être plus haut font encore
la question que vous me posiez et vous
ne posiez c'est de faire en sorte qu'une
traduction législative et au moment où
parfois la démocratie représentative est
mise en doute en particulier parfois
parce qu'ils manifestent
il est bon aussi que la démocratie
représentative à la fois dans le travail
préalable c'est à dire dans le débat
mais aussi dans la suite c'est à dire le
travail législatif puisse se saisir des
questions et donc c'est ce qui se fera
au travers des textes qui seront
examinés il ya des textes qui sont déjà
sur la table il ya des textes pour
lesquels nous avons décidé d'aménager le
calendrier je pense à la révision
constitutionnelle ou d'autres textes et
sur lequel il faudra peut-être
l'enrichir et probablement l'enrichir
des débats qui ont eu lieu
et puis peut-être des textes qui
naîtront du débat tel qu'il est en train
de se nouer sur les territoires et c'est
donc bien l'articulation entre le débat
qui doit se jouer
et puis la deuxième chose qui a la
capacité que nous aurons à traduire et
vous avez raison de dire il ya des
solutions de long terme il faudra le
dire parce qu'il ya parfois des
solutions de long terme et parfois des
solutions de court terme c'est bien dans
ce cadre là que se déroulera le débat
merci monsieur la parole et à notre
collègue esther benbassa pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes vous avez la parole ma chère
collègue monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'intérieur
mutilé éborgné défiguré subissons
quotidiennement la violence symbolique
et sociales imposées par les politiques
gouvernementales c'est désormais dans
leur chair que sont frappées de nombreux
gilet jaune face à cette crise majeure
et a2 l'assemblement protestataires qui
ne sont certes pas exemple parfois de
violence
l'unique réponse apportée par de
l'exécutif est une répétition
disproportionnée plus de 5600
interpellations et gardes à vue plus de
mille condamnations ont le sens environ
3000 blessés dont 94 grave les violences
policières vont crescendo avec l' usage
toujours plus dangereuse grenades de
désencerclement flash ball est honteux
lbd40 sans oublier le tabassage et le
gazage quasi systématique
daniel bas c'est vrai c'est vous c'est
que ça vous énerve
voilà derniers corps dernier cas en date
vous vous taisez quand même non bon
dernier record en date olivier père de
famille de 47 ans pompier volontaire
manifestant pacifiquement avec son
épouse le 12 janvier à bordeaux
touché à la tête par un tir de flashball
il est dans le coma
quand on sait qu en principe seuls les
torses et les membres inférieurs peuvent
être visés par les policiers depuis
l'acte du 1 du mouvement des gilet jaune
l'igpn a été saisie de 200 cas de
violences policières soit 118 font
actuellement l'objet d'une enquête
interne
ma question est simple
n'est-il pas temps de mettre un terme à
cette répression d'une brutalité
intolérable et d'interdire comme le
préconise le défenseur des droits
l'utilisation d'armes non létales pas
les forces de l'ordre qu'on vous
répondre la parole et secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur lune elle avait la parole
monsieur willis monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice benbassa d'abord le
contexte je tiens à rappeler le contexte
dans lequel se déroulent les
manifestations auxquelles vous faites
allusion un contexte de manifestations
qui ne sont jamais déclarait jamais
encadré avec des manifestants qui va
parfois mais très souvent s'en prennent
de manière extrêmement violente et
agressive aux policiers en leur jetant
divers projectiles et beaucoup nous
disent qu'ils ont sentiment plutôt qu'on
cherche à les tuer c'est dans ce
contexte là que s'organise et qui est
prévue la riposte policière madame la
sénatrice et uniquement dans ce contexte
là quand il ya des agressions ou quand
il s'agit de disperser d attroupement
violent et ce contexte il est
extrêmement encadrées et vous le savez
très bien la riposte des policiers elle
est toujours proportionnée elle se fait
avec ce qu'on appelle des armes
intermédiaires dont les conditions
d'utilisation sont très encadrées très
contrôlé très surveillé ce ne sont pas
200 plaintes dont il a été saisi l'igpn
mais ce sont 80 une enquête judiciaire
qui ont été ouvertes pour des suspicions
de violences policières
donc il y à bien un contrôle qui est
exercée la riposte elle s'effectue de
manière proportionnée mais face à de
véritables agressions dont font l'objet
les forces de l'ordre alors même alors
même qu'elles sont là pour nous protéger
pour protéger ces manifestations et je
vous le dis les manifestantes un
comportement qui est extrêmement violent
et c'est cette riposte là qui s'organise
alors vous parlez des moyens
intermédiaire vous parler des moyens
intermédiaire de défense effectivement
les policiers utilisent des grenades
lacrymogènes des grenades de
désencerclement et parfois quand ils
sont vraiment acculé le lanceur de
balles de défense
mais encore une fois dans des conditions
très strictes et nous avons rappelé avec
christophe castaner à l'ensemble des
policiers ces conditions d usage et ses
conditions d'emploi et je peux vous dire
que si les policiers n'avaient pas ne
faisait pas usage de ses moyens de
défense peut-être que certains d'entre
eux auraient été lynchées comme nous
l'avons beaucoup vu nous avons beaucoup
vu des tentatives de lynchage des
membres des forces de l'ordre
et ça ça n'est pas acceptable et c'est
ça que nous voulons que vous condamniez
[Applaudissements]
la parole
la parole est au président patrick
kanner pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre nous allons donc dans
le grand débat lancé par le président de
la république
et comme nous l'avons déjà dit
publiquement les parlementaires
socialistes prendront toute leur part
dans ce débat sur le terrain dans les
communes
nous sommes de fervents défenseurs du
dialogue et du débat politique avec les
français nous redirons à cette occasion
les propositions que nous vous avons
déjà fait et que vous n'avez
malheureusement pas suivi
seulement il est une proposition dont
nous ne savons plus si nous aurons le
droit de la formule et je veux bien sûr
parler du rétablissement du sf
le président de la république a soufflé
le chaud et le froid sur ce point click
devons nous croire le président de la
lettre français qui exclut toute remise
en cause de sa ligne économique et
social ou le président du débat en
normandie qui ouvre le droit de parler
de l' isf ce sujet de l' isf pose plus
largement la question de la prise en
compte de la parole des français dans ce
débat à l'image de vos recule contre un
sur une partie de l'augmentation de la
csg pour les retraités sur la taxe
carbone sur le coup de pouce au smic via
la prime d'activité sur vos 80 km/heure
désormais entendez-vous infléchir votre
politique économique et sociale si
contestée où ce débat ne sera-t-il qu'un
exercice de communication sans suite
enfin monsieur le premier ministre
permettez moi une dernière question
comment envisagez vous la conclusion de
ce grand débat accepterez-vous comme
vous l'ont demandé certains syndicats
que la fin du grand débat prenne la
forme d'une vraie négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux que vous avez
négligé jusqu'ici on a parole
le premier minis jeux le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président caennais
vous m'interrogez sur le grand débat son
organisation le sens qu'il peut avoir la
porte et qu'il aura et ses conclusions
plus exactement la méthode retenue au
terme de ce grand débat ya un certain
nombre de questions sur lequel je peux
parfaitement vous répondre ce débat est
organisé pendant les deux mois qui
viennent pour faire en sorte que chacun
tous les français où qu'ils vivent et ça
compte
quel que soit leur âge leurs occupations
professionnelles leur statut puisse
s'exprimer
vous savez comme moi monsieur le
président que il est déraisonnable
d'imaginer interdire aux français de
s'exprimer que si on leur si on les
invitait à ne parler que d'un sujet il
aurait toute liberté toute latitude pour
s'exprimer sur l'ensemble des sujets
qu'ils veulent voix évoquée vous le
savez je le sais aussi et c'est parce
que nous le savons que le président de
la république a souhaité cadre est entre
guillemets le débat non pas pour faire
de tel ou tel sujet des sujets qui
serait tabou c'est à dire qu'on ne
pourrait pas évoqué mais pour dire quel
est le cadre dans lequel nous allons
prendre en compte ce que diront les
français
prenons un exemple qui parce qu'il sera
évident montrera la logique
imaginez ce que je ne crois pas ce que
je n'espère pas évidemment que les
français veuillent mettre en cause la
forme républicaine de nos institutions
je ne crois pas qu'ils le feront même si
même si
même si nous devons faire attention à
préserver ce qui nous semble parfois
acquis imaginez qu'il le dise vous voyez
bien vous voyez bien monsieur le
président que nous ne nous engageons
rions pas dans cette logique c'est bien
évident je prends cet exemple et il est
tellement excessif que il vous indique
que clairement les choses
les éléments qui constituent le socle de
l'engagement du président de la
république au moment de l'élection aux
présidentielles qui constituent le socle
de l'engagement des parlementaires de la
majorité ont été acquis au moment d'une
élection
je pense que vous reconnaîtrez comme moi
qu'il ne peut pas enfin qu'ils ne
peuvent pas être écartés qu'il constitue
là aussi un des éléments qui font de la
confiance
un des éléments sur lequel cette
majorité que vous avez parfaitement le
droit de critiquer monsieur le sénateur
mais un des éléments sur lesquels cette
majorité s'est engagée et la légitimité
qui découlent de l'élection doit
évidemment aussi aussi être respectées
autrement dit monsieur le président un
certain nombre de questions ont été
posées beaucoup 35 ou 36 je crois en eux
directement par le président de la
république dans sa lettre qu'il a
adressée aux français en répondant à ces
questions en s'exprimant sur ces sujets
les français vont nous donner un certain
nombre d'indications
il appartiendra ensuite au gouvernement
au parlement à l'ensemble de ceux qui
concourent au débat public d'en faire
leur miel de s'en inspirer dans la
réponse aux questions profondes et
anciennes qui taraude notre société
c'est dans cet esprit que nous nous
engageons et vous évoquez la question la
proposition qui a été formulée par
certaines organisations syndicales pas
toutes mais certaines qui était
d'ailleurs reprise par certaines
associations d'élus d'organiser au terme
de l'exercice une grande conférence
territoriale et sociale qui permettrait
à l'ensemble des acteurs en question
d'échanger sur ce qui ressort du grand
débat et de le transformer le cas
échéant en propositions de solutions
c'est une bonne proposition je l'entends
je pense que nous allons lancer le débat
que ce débat doit vivre et que au fur à
mesure qu'il vivra nous pourrons
répondre à un certain nombre de
questions et de propositions comme celle
ci mais je crois monsieur le président
que si nous voulons être logique
alors il faut faire en sorte que ceux
qui formulent l'ambition de participer
au terme du débat la définition des
solutions choisies ce d'une façon ou
d'une autre de participer aux débats
pendant qu'il a lieu sinon il y aurait
quelque chose de comment dirais-je
curieux à faire en sorte qu'on réclame
de participer à la fin mais qu'on ne
participe pas pendant le débat si ce
débat prospère comme comme nous le
souhaitons et comme je crois un très
grand nombre de français l'espère alors
peut-être faudra-t-il faire droit à
cette proposition
je crois qu'il est un peu tôt pour
répondre à cette question je pense qu'il
faut laisser aux débats le soin d'être
lancée en garantissant aux français ce
que nous avons fait ce que le président
de la république a dit ce que je redis
ici devant les sénateurs que nous
tiendrons compte des éléments qui sont
formulées à l'intérieur du cadre qui a
été proposée par le président la
république monsieur le président keller
monsieur prix ministre j'entends votre
réponse et je vous confirme que les
parlementaires socialistes participeront
à votre grand débat au grand débat
national qui a été lancé par le
président de la république la démocratie
participative peut être enrichie par la
démocratie participative représentative
pardon je dis quoi inverse et compris en
tout cas la démocratie participative ne
peut pas se substituer à la démocratie
représentative et je tiens à insister
sur le fait que nous défendrons bec et
ongles bicamérisme monsieur le premier
ministre
et que et que naturellement le sénat le
sénat comme lanceur d'alert doit être
respectée et parfois vous pourriez être
bien inspiré à écouter ses conclusions
merci
la parole est à jean louis lagourgue
pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires en cher
collègue monsieur le président chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur le
15 décembre dernier un navire de pêche
est intercepté au large de la réunion
avec à son bord près de 70 personnes
dont des femmes et des enfants tous
originaires du sri lanka
quelques jours plus tard un autre bateau
accosté transportant cette fois sept
passagers et portant à cinq le nombre de
navires qui ont rejoint la réunion en
2018 en provenance et cette île voisine
de l'inde situé à 4200 km des côtes
réunionnaises
ces faits laissent penser qu'une
nouvelle filière est en train de se
structurer pour fuir la crise politique
ethnique et religieuse qui divise
l'ancien celle en dix ans après la fin
de la guerre civile faisaient la mort de
près de cent mille personnes
la minorité tamoule et chrétienne reste
en proie aux persécutions la réunion
représente une porte d'entrée vers la
france pays des droits de l'homme où la
diaspora sri lankaise compte environ
cent cinquante mille personnes sur les
quelques 4 80 migrants qui ont rejoint
la réunion en l'espace de dix mois
certains ont formulé des demandes
d'asile d'autres ont déjà été reconduits
chez eux avec les conséquences que l'on
peut imaginer
au delà de nous alerter sur le drame
humain que vit cette population
l'ouverture de cette nouvelle voie
migratoire migratoire vers la réunion
suscite de vives inquiétudes de la
population
mais question monsieur le ministre on
donc les suivantes les autorités
dispose-t-elle de moyens adéquats pour
assurer la surveillance des côtes
réunionnaises
quelle position le gouvernement compte
il adopter face à ce phénomène aussi
soudain qu'inattendu qui touche la
réunion et comment accompagner cette
population sans risquer une
amplification du flux migratoires je
vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et secrétaire d'état auprès de
1000 à terme polonaise
tu me lis le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur donc effectivement je vous
confirme que depuis le mois de mars de
l'année dernière nous avons enregistré
l'arrivée de quatre navires sur les
côtes réunionnaises donc avec un certain
nombre de personnes qui ont fait un
périple de plus de 4000 km en mer et
donc les autos les autorités françaises
à la réunion donc ont mis en place un
dispositif d'abord sanitaire d'accueil
de prise en charge
et puis un dispositif de prise en charge
administrative qui a effectivement
conduit à prendre encore à prendre en
compte
parfois des demandes d'asile parfois ce
sont des décisions de non admission qui
ont été prises et comme vous l'avez
souligné il y a eu également des
éloignements effectif auquel il a été
procédé la politique qui était mise en
oeuvre est une politique qui a visé
d'abord à renforcer la surveillance des
côtes comme vous le souhaitez bien
évidemment à la réunion mais aussi en
bien bien bien en aval de cela de
prendre contact avec les autorités du
sri lanka pour définir ensemble une
politique qui conduit aller à les
inciter à détecter des départs et ce
sont plusieurs navires qui ont été
empêchés de quitter le sri lanka pour se
rendre à la réunion donc c'était quelque
chose d'assez le positif et puis bien
évidemment cette politique nous allons
la poursuivre avec le sri lanka puisque
nous allons avoir une réunion avec les
autorités du sri lanka à la direction
générale des étrangers en france qui se
tiendra le 25 janvier pour aborder
précisément 7,7 c'est cette thématique
voyez bien que notre ambition il est à
la fois d'être protecteur du droit de
protection auquel ont droit légitimement
certain nombre de personnes mais en même
temps être également très ferme pour
éviter que ne se reconstitue une filière
l'immigration clandestine du sri lanka
vers la réunion et au final une nouvelle
filière de traite des êtres humains
merci que la gauche merci
la parole est à notre collègue
marc-philippe daubresse pour le groupe
l'est républicain
la parole monsieur le premier ministre
dans le livre révolution qu'il écrivait
juste avant d'être élu président de la
république
emmanuel macron disait ceci aujourd'hui
des français ont l'impression que leur
gouvernement ne gouverne plus l'europe
les partis les marchés les sondages la
rue il existe une confusion sur le
détenteur du pouvoir
quand il n'ya pas de clarté des
gouvernements le peuple se cabre il faut
savoir expliquer plutôt que de faire de
la communication
une nouvelle étape de la déconcentration
de l'état est nécessaire
je crois dans un nouveau partage
démocratique c'est le fondement de la
république contractuelle dont nous avons
besoin à république qui fait confiance
aux territoires à la société et aux
acteurs pour se transformer les
collectivités locales et leurs aux élus
doivent jouer un rôle accru c'est une
nouvelle étape de transfert des pouvoirs
vers ces collectivités que nous vous
devons décider nous ne saurions mieux
dire monsieur le premier ministre au
moment où la crise des gis légende se
traduit par une rupture banal du living
rupture brutale du lien de confiance
entre le peuple son président et son
gouvernement
pouvez vous nous expliquer pourquoi
depuis deux ans le président de la
république a fait très exactement le
contraire de ce que préconisait le
candidat macro enr centralisant outrance
toujours plus et en rejetant le rôle
prééminent des mères que vous reprenez
subitement en considération pouvez-vous
e s vous pète enfin prêt à mettre en
oeuvre les conditions d'une
déconcentration de l'état comme voulu
comme on le disait ainsi qu'une nouvelle
étape de décentralisation massive et
d'expérimentation faisant confiance aux
élus locaux et aux partenaires sociaux
comme vous le demander dans les
conférences le président du sénat qui
est dans la constitution un garant de
l'équilibré des pouvoirs et des terry
par maaf êtes vous prêts à changer
radicalement de méthode en agissant du
bas vers le haut et non plus du haut
vers le bas pour éviter que votre grand
débat ne se transforme en grande débâcle
pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre en charge des
relations avec le parlement ce ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur daubresse vous remercier de
votre question parce que ça permet au
delà de la scène lecture qui sont les
vôtres et des citations que vous faites
de peut-être redire et ray et repréciser
ce qu'est la politique du gouvernement
et notamment dans le grand débat à vrai
dire on a vu d'ailleurs je trouve un
exercice mardi dernier avec le président
de la république avec les maires qui
était un exercice qui a démontré pour
ceux qui pouvaient en douter y compris
parmi certains manifestants le rôle des
maires leur capacité à saisir la
situation leur territoire et à être les
représentants de leur territoire le
gouvernement depuis qu'il est installé
il a envoyé un certain nombre de
messages alors peut-être n'ont-ils pas
été assez perçu le premier c'est là
monsieur daubresse vous avez été maire
d'une grande commune lambersart je suis
a été maire d'une commune un peu plus au
sud de ce département et donc nous
partageons cette connaissance je crois
et cet amour des territoires et des
collectivités locales et donc le
gouvernement avait décidé alors que
pendant les cinq années précédentes ces
dotations avait baissé fortement de
stabiliser les dotations mais c'était un
signal c'est peut-être pas la question
mais c'était un signal de confiance qui
avait été fait obstacle aux
collectivités et aussi peut-être même si
ça a pu être mal perçu au travers de la
contractualisation la deuxième chose
c'est que le gouvernement essaie le
texte que nous aurons à débattre même
s'il a été reporté et le président la
république devant le congrès des maires
en 2017 avait indiqué qu'il souhaitait
qu'une nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation super avec le droit à
la différenciation
quoi de mieux que le droit à la
différenciation pour permettre aux
collectivités de se saisir des choses et
puis le troisième point parce que le
président de la république en a parlé au
maire nous étions plutôt collectivement
me semble-t-il est compris dans les
associations d'élus a pensé qu'il
fallait opérer une pause sur les grandes
réformes territoriales qui avait donné
un sentiment un peu de tourbillon aux
uns et aux autres
ceci étant à l'expérience et à
l'expérience que vous avez que nous
avons tous on voit bien qu'il ya une
question autour de la loi notre autour
des périmètres autour des compétences et
cela aussi le président de la république
a déclaré qu'il se déclarerait ouvert à
des débats des ajustements pas pour tout
refonder une fois de plus mais pour
répondre aux exigences pratiques des
mers et c'est bien ça qui sera l'enjeu
aussi du grand débat
merci hugo brasse messieurs messieurs
min zhu comprendre et au vu de ce que
j'ai lu qu'on prof préfère les preuves
d'amour aux déclarations d'amour nous
attendons une grande conférence
territoriale
après le grand débat et une grande
conférence sociale nous attendons une
loi décentralisation et nous attendons
que vous mettiez en pratique les choses
en respectant le sénat qui est quand
même la première assemblée désignée par
la constitution pour représenter les
collectivités territoriales
merci la parole est à notre collègue
vincent delahaye pour le groupe de
l'union centriste avait la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues les français regardent les
sociétés d'autoroute avec suspicion
et pour cause si la qualité de service y
est globalement élevé les tarifs le sont
aussi
ce qui est inversement proportionnelle à
la transparence financière qui régissent
cet oligopole depuis les conditions de
privatisation très discutable de 2005
les mêmes opérateurs prétendent ne pas
gagner beaucoup d'argent
il nous en ferait presque pleuré et
pourtant ces sociétés ne savent pas quoi
inventer pour demander aux gouvernements
successifs d'allonger la durée de
concession
malheureusement l'état désargenté cède à
chaque fois aux mirages de travaux plus
ou moins utiles
réalisé par leurs propres filiales
contre quelques années encore de
punition tarifaire pour les
automobilistes
sans parler des turpitudes électoraliste
d'une ministres du précédent quinquennat
qui vont conduire à alourdir de nouveau
la facture dès le 1er février
à l'heure où les français veulent
retrouver du pouvoir d'achat exigent
plus de transparence
il est temps de faire la lumière sur
cette situation ces sociétés serait soit
disant prête à faire un geste
or nous ne connaissons pas les
conditions financières de ce geste
nous sommes donc pas capable d'apprécier
si l'effort est réel ou s'il s'agit
d'une aumône presque insultantes
le gouvernement étudie actuellement ses
propositions à partir de quel niveau les
jugera t-il acceptable les sociétés
d'autoroutes abandonneront elle 20 30 ou
50 %
les augmentations prévues il semble
aussi que leur lobbying soit intense
pour prendre en charge de nouvelles
sections d'autoroute contre un
allègement de la durée des concessions
qu'en est-il pouvez-vous nous assurer
que les discussions seront conduites
sans opacité et en prenant en compte la
réelle situation financière de ses
sociétés pour vous répondre la parole et
co viril d'état
les listes de la transition écologique
et solidaire monsieur de rugy monsieur
le ministre d'état
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur de l'est nous partageons
globalement votre analyse et comme vous
le savez les sociétés d'autoroutes
les tarifs des sociétés d'autoroutes
tarifs des péages sont fixés par des
règles qui sont dans les contrats de
concessions d'autoroutes
d'ailleurs c'est ça ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui puisque la première
concession a été créée par une loi de
1955 pour la société escota qui gère
notamment des autos dans le sud de la
france et par ailleurs en 2005
en effet les sociétés d'autoroutes qui
appartenait majoritairement à l'état ont
été privatisées ce qui à l'époque a
rapporté de l'argent à l'état mais ce
qui évidemment ne nous donne plus aucune
marge de manoeuvre pour renégocier les
contrats de ces sociétés
et si nous faisions des promesses
démagogiques et vous avez bien fait de
le rappeler et commision français on va
pouvoir baisser les tarifs
et bien cela serait répercuté les années
suivantes et nous le payons encore
aujourd'hui ce qui a été fait en 2015 ou
en effet il ya eu une promesse
démagogique de baisse des tarifs et donc
se répercuter encore cette année les
automobilistes vont payer cette promesse
parce que c'est pas ce qu'ils font les
promesses qui paye ses les
automobilistes alors nous nous avons
demandé aux sociétés d'autoroutes de
faire des efforts sur la base de leurs
tarifs de leurs recettes et nous sommes
en train de négocier elisabeth bornes
ministre des transports auprès de moi
est actuellement à l'heure où je vous
parle en train de négocier avec les
sociétés d'autoroutes pour avoir des
tarifs notamment des abonnements les
automobilistes qui utilisent ces
autoroutes points et travailler tous les
jours il y en a qu'ils aient des
abonnements avec de fortes réductions
sur cet usage quotidien des autoroutes
ce qui permettra
un gain concrets pour un certain nombre
de nos compatriotes c'est ça notre
objectif et jeudi par ailleurs que nous
sommes totalement contre le fait de
prolonger encore plus ces contrats que
nous trouvons trop patent à jeu pour les
sociétés d'autoroutes
c'était la proposition des sociétés
d'autoroutes de faire un geste en
échange d'un allongement de durée
ce que nous refusons monsieur de là et
quelques secondes
oui monsieur le président j'aurais aimé
avoir la réponse sur ce qui paraissait
raisonnable au gouvernement pour
accepter ses propositions
en tout cas nous souhaitons nous dire
stop à la rentabilité maximale et stop à
la transparence minimale pour les
sociétés d'autoroutes
si la parole est à notre collègue
antoine karam pour le groupe de la
république en marche
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues dimanche dernier dix neuf
kilos de cocaïne ont été retrouvés dans
les bagages d'une mère et de ses enfants
à l'art par félix éboué de cayenne alors
je vous le montre voilà le quotidien des
guyanais en quelques années seulement la
guyane terre d'amérique du sud est
devenue un espace majeur de transit vers
l'europe
imaginez qu entre 2014 et 2018
les saisies ont augmenté de 300 35 %
passant de 145 à 631 kg
si bien que selon l'observatoire
français des drogues et des toxicomanies
près de 30% du marché français évalué
entre 25 et 30 tonnes proviendrait de la
guyane très concrètement on compterait
20 30 nuls par avion soit plus de 3000
personnes par an et seulement 10%
d'interpeller à l'origine de ce trafic
un ennemi sans visage qui se cache
derrière le destin tragique de ces mules
transportant la drogue dans leurs
bagages
lorsqu elle n'augure gîte pas au péril
de leur vie les gens témoignent ici pour
l'avoir vécu pour avoir vu une jeune
femme mourir d'overdose
en plein vol sous les yeux de son fils
samuel sont toutes nos enfants les
proies faciles de trafiquants sans
scrupules qui puise dans le vivier des
jeunes inactifs
parce que la société n'est aujourd'hui
pas en mesure de leur proposer un emploi
de leur offrir un avenir
ces jeunes risquent volontiers leur vie
contre le mirage de quelques milliers
d'euros
monsieur le ministre je vous sais
préoccupé par ce sujet je sais aussi que
les autorités sont mobilisés conscient
de l'ampleur du phénomène
force est néamoins est néanmoins de
constater que les moyens de lutter les
tribunaux sont aujourd'hui saturés que
le trafic s'accroître considérablement
avec lui le nombre de ses victimes
alors je vous le demande solennellement
le gouvernement tente ils déployer un
plan ambitieux de prévention et de lutte
contre le trafic de stupéfiants en
provenance de guyane je vous remercie
quand vous répondre la parole et
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre
monsieur lui neige monsieur monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur karam sur
le constat d'abord vous avez raison le
trafic de stupéfiants en provenance de
la guyane est en augmentation
vous savez et vous l'avez rappelé que
c'est une des voies d'acheminement d'un
pays de provenance une département de
provenance de la cocaïne qui est importé
ici en france dont qui passent par ce
département et qui provient d'afrique
centrale et d'amérique centrale par dans
et d'amérique du sud
le constat il est là avec une
augmentation et des personnes qui
parfois exposent leur vie en
transportant in corpore comme on dit
après ingestion cette cocaïne et
l'augmentation est importante
ce que nous avons mis en oeuvre compte
tenu de cette augmentation exponentielle
et après que un groupe interministériel
se soient réunis avec les ministères
concernés l'intérieur la justice
solidarité et santé et nous nous sommes
réunis pour décider
trois mesures d'abord le renforcement
significatif des contrôles au départ à
cayenne et puis à l'arrivée à orly et ce
renforcement de contrôles
il s'est accompagné d'un renforcement
des effectifs voilà pour la première
mesure et qui est en oeuvre dès à
présent s'agissant de la deuxième mesure
nous avons tout au long de l'année 2017
2018 renforcer les effectifs qui sont en
charge de la lutte contre les trafics de
stupéfiants en guyane sur le territoire
guyanais et donc ses agents ce sont des
agents de la gendarmerie nationale de la
police nationale et des douanes et qui
effectue un travail en profondeur pour
lutter contre les réseaux de trafic de
stupéfiants et puis troisième piste plus
globale
c'est ce que nous a demandé de mettre en
oeuvre le président de la république
oeuvre le premier ministre c'est un plan
global de lutte contre les trafics de
stupéfiants qui inclut dans l'action que
nous menons une collaboration un
partenariat avec les pays de provenance
de cette cocaïne pour mener une action
qui soit beaucoup plus efficace voilà
monsieur le sénateur pourrait compter
sur la détermination du miz de
l'intérieur de l'ensemble du
gouvernement pour lutter contre ce fléau
qu'est le trafic de stupéfiants et
notamment en provenance de la guyane
merci merci la parole est maintenant
notre collègue nadine grelet certes
sonné pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain vous avez la parole sur
collègue monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre du travail
le 30 décembre dernier pour les fêtes de
fin d'année paraissait un décret
d'application de la loi
joliment intitulé pour la liberté de
choisir son avenir professionnel visant
à renforcer le contrôle des chômeurs
avec l'idée que les français les plus en
difficultés les plus fragiles seraient
responsables de leur exclusion
voici donc comment ce décret entend
responsabiliser ceux qui déconne ceux
qui n'ont pas le sens de l'effort selon
les termes choquant employés sans
vergogne par le président de la
république
ainsi dès le premier refus d'une offre
le chercheur d'emploi pourra être radiés
des listes de pôle emploi
l'offre raisonnable d'emploi et
redéfinit le salaire précédent n'est
plus un argument de refus dès le premier
manquement la location est supprimé non
suspendues ce qui permettait auparavant
de conserver ses droits
enfin la surveillance sera assurée par
le journal de bord numérique qui
permettra de contrôler en temps réel les
chômeurs les syndicats ont bien sûr
fortement réagi contre ce nouveau
caporalisme déshumanisé à l'égard des
demandeurs d'emploi on ne peut vouloir
baisser le chômage en radiant les
allocataires ou en accroissant la
précarité des exclus emplois en raison
de la masse des dossiers suivi
l'explosion des cdd de moins
moi les agents de pôle emploi estime que
ce climat de suspicion dénature leur
mission sans compter le fait que vous
avez supprimer 800 postes dans la
dernière loi de finances ne serait-il
pas temps madame la ministre à l'heure
où vous semblez vouloir adopter une
autre attitude à l'égard des syndicats
et en vue du grand débat de modifier
votre analyse de la situation d'emploi
de privilégier enfin l'accompagnement
plutôt que la sanction des plus
précaires et questionner non pas
seulement l'employabilité des personnes
mais le nombre et la qualité des emplois
proposés par les entreprises pour vous
répondre la parole à madame la ministre
du travail monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice nadine grelet c'est
retenez vous m'interrogez sur le décret
du 30 décembre qui intervient en
application de la loi pour la liberté de
choisir son avenir professionnel
promulguée le 5 septembre dernier
alors quel est le sens du contrôle hilla
à 100 ce double le premier c'est que
dans tout système de solidarité
collective il faut un équilibre des
droits et des devoirs
le deuxième sens c'est que on constate
empiriquement et ça vient des équipes de
pôle emploi que le contrôle parfois
permet de remobiliser
je vous donne un exemple sur les 300
milles contrôles aléatoires café pôle
emploi dans la dernière vague sursaut
demandeurs d'emploi 66 chercher
activement un emploi 20% étaient
découragés et on peut le comprendre
il baissait après avoir fait des tas et
des tas de démarches il ya un jour on
baisse les bras parce que c'est un peu
désespérant
le fait de dans le contrôle de s'en
apercevoir a permis de remobiliser et le
demandeur d'emploi et les équipes de
pôle emploi avec des très beaux succès
ensuite
et puis 14% ne cherchez pas activement
un emploi et n'avait pas de difficultés
particulières de santé de logement
d'éloignement ou des difficultés qu'on
peut comprendre et qui sont prises en
compte dans le contrôle alors pour cela
oui le contrôle a été revu pourquoi
parce qu'il était également injuste et
inéquitable
jusqu'ici dans le cadre de
l'offre de recherche dans l'offre
raisonnable d'emploi que d'ailleurs les
gouvernements précédents n'ont jamais
supprimé donc l'avait soutenu également
il y avait un système injuste c'est
considéré de la même façon une femme
seule qui habite dans une zone rurale et
qui doit contraindre par les horaires de
crèches pour pouvoir placer son enfant
est travaillée qui vont être sanctionnés
parce qu'elle refusait un emploi mais
par contre le cadre dans une métropole
sur un métier où il n'y a pas de chômage
lui avait n'avait pas forcément de
sanctions et donc on a simplement fait
quelque chose de plus équitable qui
vient de l'expérience du terrain des
agents de pôle emploi c'est que
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus être
sanctionnés de façon on ne peut pas être
pénalisé pour une un sujet sur lequel on
n'a pas la prise est concrètement ça
veut dire que dès le premier jour le
demandeur d'emploi au conseiller pôle
emploi vont définir sur quelles bases
l'emploi peut être chercher et contrôler
les retenaient madame la mise ou
poursuivis une logique technocratique
avec ce décret vous ajoutez de la
culpabilité à la précarité vous mettez
en danger une population déjà affectés
par ce sentiment d'injustice
ce décret très mauvais augure en vue de
la réforme systémique de l'assurance
chômage actuellement sur la table de
négociation vous parler d' équilibre des
droits et devoirs qu'en est il des
fraudeurs fiscaux par ailleurs la parole
et à l'autre collègue catherine de roche
pour le groupe l'est républicain vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
et porte sur la politique fiscale
depuis plusieurs mois nous avons assisté
à des atermoiements successifs du
gouvernement je ne reviendrai pas sur la
taxe sur les carburants sur l'impôt sur
les sociétés l'existant l'exit tax les
charges sur les sur les heures
supplémentaires la la csg et bien
d'autres la liste est très longue et
récemment nous avons eu en effet des
déclarations contradictoires sur la taxe
d'habitation sur l'impôt sur les
successions ou sur les sf mardi dernier
le président la république a rajouté
j'allais dire au catalogue les 80 km
heure les réversions donc ma question
est simple pouvez vous éclairer le sénat
ou tenter d'éclairer le sénat sur la
feuille de route en matière de politique
fiscale pour répondre aux exigences
fixées par le président de la république
pour vous répondre dans la parole et co
vis de l'économie et des finances
monsieur bruno le maire de la parole
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice vais vous rassurer sur notre
feuille de route
notre feuille de route c'est baisser les
impôts baisser d impôt pour les ménages
baisser les impôts pour les entreprises
bc impôts pour les ménages la taxe
d'habitation
vous connaissez la conviction sur le
sujet j'estime que cet impôt doit être
totalement supprimée pour l'ensemble des
ménages
ça n'exclut pas que la question soit
posée aux français mais je vous rappelle
la position qui est la mienne
s'agissant de la fiscalité sur le
capital lisf le prélèvement forfaitaire
unique
je vous redis aussi ma conviction forte
il faut baisser l'impôt sur le capital
pour que nos entreprises puissent
investir innover créer des emplois
et donc je suis favorable à ce que nous
maintenions la suppression de l'impôt
sur la fortune et le prélèvement
forfaitaire unique mais vous êtes de ce
côté-là de l'hémicycle comme je le pense
dans tout cet hémicycle favorable à la
réindustrialisation de notre pays il n'y
aura pas de reconquête industrielle en
france sans baisser les impôts et les
taxes sur le capital et sans baisser les
impôts de production sur l'industrie ça
fait 20 ans que l'on fait croire aux
français qu'on peut avoir une industrie
forte avec des impôts élevés et bien le
million d'emplois supprimés dans
l'industrie montrent que ce n'est pas la
bonne voie
nous poursuivrons donc la baisse des
impôts sur l'industrie et sur l'ensemble
des entreprises françaises en ramenant
l'impôt sur les sociétés de 33 % à 25 %
en france d'ici 2022
ça n'exclut pas non plus belles âmes des
roches baisser les impôts pour tous les
français baisser les impôts pour
l'économie en france 2 un point minimum
sur cinq ans ça n'empêche pas non plus
d'aller chercher l'argent là où il se
trouve et de mettre en place comme nous
allons le faire une juste taxe sur les
géants du numérique qui s'appliquera à
compter du 1er janvier 2019 pour que
tous les genres du numérique payant
france le même montant d'impôt que nos
pme et de petites entreprises
madame de roche
je vous remercie monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le ministre vous avez
donnez vos propres convictions mais nous
avons beaucoup de déclarations de vos
collègues du gouvernement qui sont
contraires à ce que vous venez tirs or
on a eu vingt mois d'une politique
péremptoire avec aucun écho à nos
propositions
maintenant nous sommes sûr parti pour
quelques mois d'incertitude jusqu'à la
fin du débat mais que de temps perdu et
que n'avez vous écoutez les sénateurs
nous qui sommes au plus près du terrain
et qui connaissons la vraie vie c'est
pas tango permanent déclaratif sont
terriblement anxiogène pour nos
concitoyens que ce soit les chefs
d'entreprise les agriculteurs les
particuliers les classes enfin les
classes moyennes les familles cela
change tout le temps et chacun voit bien
ce qui est donné d'une main repris
doublement voire plus de l'autre côté
donc je terminerai par une formule d'un
économiste pourtant modérées la
politique fiscale du gouvernement ce
n'est plus une usine à gaz mais toute
une zone industrielle
merci par l'état jean pierre moga bord
un groupe de l'union centriste de la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre j'attire votre
attention sur la création et
l'exploitation d'une retenue d'eau
collective le lac de caussade en
lot-et-garonne
il s'agit de la colline r 2 - 2 millions
de mètres cubes destinés à l'irrigation
la réalisation de ce lac serait pour les
agriculteurs en espoirs une partie des
eaux de pluies hivernales pourraient
être stockées pour être utilisé en
période estivale
ce serait aussi une opportunité de
maintenir un étiage convenable du petit
ruisseau en aval de la retenue pendant
l'été les porteurs de projets dans le
monde agricole comme d'ailleurs dans
d'autres secteurs se heurte à des textes
qui rendent camille quasiment impossible
la réalisation de telles opérations
c'est peut-être cette complexité des
lois et des normes qui a poussé les
agriculteurs en fendre la loi et
entreprend dans la construction de
l'ouvragé solution que je déplore mais
qui est une règle une réalité
dans ce contexte nous risquons de vivre
à nouveau si vs
mais ainsi ves ou alors pas céder à dist
il y aurait des agriculteurs maintenir
la paix sociale avec le monde agricole
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard est une
priorité absolue monsieur le ministre
les agriculteurs sont déjà respectable
qui doivent irriguer leurs cultures pour
nourrir la population
aujourd'hui ils doivent faire face à
d'importantes mutations comme jamais ils
sont à bout je vous demande donc quelle
mesure vous envisagez de prendre afin de
résoudre ce problème et d'en sortir par
le haut en fait vous le savez comme moi
le changement climatique est
malheureusement en marche le monde de
rural va vivre des périodes de
sécheresses de plus en plus importante
aussi envisagez vous d'adapter la loi
sur l'eau afin de mieux répondre aux
défis majeurs majeur qui nous attendent
merci françois de rugy milices d'état
résidents mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le seul sénateur moga vous
avez raison la question de l'accès à
l'eau est un des enjeux clés des effets
du dérèglement climatique et
particulièrement dans la grande région
sud ouest où on constate déjà
aujourd'hui tous les ans de graves
déficits en eau et c'est pour cela que
c'est la priorité que nous avons fixés à
la deuxième phase des assises de l'eau
donc tous les acteurs élus locaux mais
aussi représentants des agriculteurs des
industriels des consommateurs qui
réfléchissent sur la réforme de notre
politique de l'eau c'est bien
l'adaptation dérèglement climatique et
notamment la question du stockage de
l'eau car il faut bien appeler les
choses par leur nom
s'agissant de la situation à caussade
je tiens à rappeler que ce projet n'a
jamais pu apporter la preuve de sa
compatibilité avec le schéma
d'aménagement et de gestion de l'eau le
fameux sage que tous les élus locaux
connaissent bien et le respect des
directives européennes
en vigueur et cela malgré plusieurs
alertes et c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé
avec le ministre de l'agriculture à
l'époque donc stéphane travert le
retrait de l'arrêté préfectoral de juin
2018 qui avait été pris contre l'avis de
deux préfets de région et nous en avons
d'ailleurs tiré les conséquences
concernant la préfecture de département
malgré cela le projet a été lancé il
légalement par le porteur de projet et
vous l'avez dit un peu en quelque sorte
en situation inversée de sivens qui est
malheureusement de triste mémoire j'ai
donc donné immédiatement des
instructions pour que l'ensemble des
démarches soient engagées et notamment
par la justice pour constater
l'illégalité des travaux ce qui a été
fait il existe d'ailleurs des systèmes
d'astreintes financières pour non
respect des décisions de justice et qui
vont être enclenchée par l'état mais cet
exemple négatif ne doit pas nous
détourner de l'objectif que nous
partageons avec didier gay au ministre
de l'agriculture de trouver les
solutions concrètes pour le stockage de
l'eau la gestion de la ressource en eau
avec des fortes pluies parfois à
certains moments et des périodes de
sécheresse il y à l'exemple des deux
sèvres qui peut nous être très
instructif et nous allons donc agir dans
ce sens merci la parole est maintenant
notre collègue julien bargeton pour le
groupe de la république en bas à feu la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues la liberté de la presse
à côté du suffrage universel c'est la
pensée de tous à côté du gouvernement de
tous a tenté à l'une c'est attenter à
l'autre ainsi s'exprime et victor hugo
l'un de nos éminents collègues
cet édifice commun est aujourd'hui trop
souvent attaqué les agressions répétées
de journalistes sont inadmissibles et
met en danger le pacte républicain en
s'attaquant à la presse en bloquant la
diffusion de journaux en menaçant une
journaliste de viol comme à toulouse en
insultant en permanence sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est la république qu on
agresse mais personne ne tordra le bras
à la république
la france n'acceptera jamais de
banaliser le bâillon ailleurs la liberté
de la presse c'est peut-être un luxe
c'est peut-être une chute une chimère en
france c'est un droit fondamental
informé créer le débat
divertir et je n'oublie pas que dans le
monde des journalistes ont payé de leurs
prix cette liberté et je n'oublie pas
les victimes de l'attentât du 7 janvier
charlie hebdo qui ont prié de leurs prix
de leur vie cette liberté fondamentale
alors comme les français gardent en
mémoire ce souvenir il la meilleure
façon d'honorer nos morts de les
respecter c'est de défendre sur le
terrain comme en ligne la liberté de la
presse et le travail des journalistes
monsieur le ministre à l'heure où là
toute la france s'apprête à débattre
quelles sont les mesures que le
gouvernement prend pour défendre cette
liberté et sanctionner ceux qui
souhaiteraient y attentes et je vous
remercie
merci pour vous répondre la parole et au
belize par le charge des relations avec
le parlement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bert jetons merci de votre
question dans ses fondements et puis
aussi dans l'occasion que nous offre le
pouvoir répondre aux questions que vous
posez la déclaration des droits de
l'homme de 1789 indique que la libre
communication des pensées et des
opinions est un des droits de l'homme
les plus précieux de l'homme
sans cette liberté sur les médias sans
les journalistes et leur travail il n'y
a pas de démocratie possible des
journalistes en sont les vigies une
démocratie qui ne défend pas sa presse
est une démocratie qui s'oublie ligne de
moulins est une démocratie qui se nuit
le journaliste peut évidemment être
contestées critiquer doit bien sûr faire
l'objet de controverses
il doit aussi rendre des comptes mais
rien ne justifie les appels à la
défiance puis à la haine puis à la
violence que nous avons entendues et
rien ne justifiera que l'on cherche par
la force ou par la peur à bâillonner les
uns ou les autres dans ce débat qui nous
occupe où les journées sont de plus en
plus souvent mis en cause dans le débat
public
il est une arme essentielle c'est
l'éducation aux médias
et nous ne ménageons pas des efforts sur
ce sujet le traitement de l'information
appelle aussi les exigences
déontologiques la plus forte c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement a confié une
mission à emmanuel hogg
comme vous le savez qu'ils procèdent
depuis quelques semaines à une
concertation la plus large possible sur
le sujet pour aboutir à des propositions
défendre la liberté de la presse est
aussi lutter contre les tentatives de
manipulation de l'information qui
sévissent et que nous avons vu encore à
l'oeuvre c'est la vision qui préside à
la loi promulguée le 25 décembre dernier
c'est aussi soutenir le modèle
économique de la presse et c'est ce que
nous faisons au niveau européen et c'est
ce que le travail qui est fait aussi
dans les deux assemblées sur ce sont ces
défend la défendent la liberté de la
presse est aussi rendre possible la
diffusion des idées sur le tout le
territoire et c'est pour cela que nous
prenons à bras le corps la question de
la distribution de la presse en droite
soutenant le redressement de presstalis
défendre les libertés la démocratie tu
es aussi défendre les permettrait de le
dire les parlementaires menacer les élus
locaux menacer les citoyens privés leurs
exercices de circulation leurs exercices
leur libre exercice de circulation ou de
droit simplement à exercer une activité
c'est défendre les institutions menacés
ou les ministères envahissent et défend
les parlementaires je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure et donc nous cette question
démocratique elle touche la fois la
presse vous voyez les éléments qu'on a
sur la table et il touche à l'ensemble
des institutions et je crois que c'est
un sentiment que nous partageons les uns
les autres je remercie ses bords je
tourne rond la parole est à notre
collègue muriel jourda pour le groupe
l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le premier ministre
ma question s'adresse à vous je crois en
bicamérisme qui garantit une démocratie
mieux équilibrée il n'est pas de
république forte sans institutions
puissantes nez de temps troublés nos
institutions sont résistantes aux crises
et aux turbulences joueurs que sur
d'autres connu monsieur le premier
ministre le discours d' emmanuel macron
président de la république au congrès
lors des mois de juillet 2017 et 2018
et il avait raison nous connaissons une
crise sociale une crise culturelle une
crise territoriales mais nous ne
connaissons pas de crise des
institutions pour autant dans sa lettre
aux français le président de la
république met en discussion la
transformation du sénat quelles sont vos
intentions à l'égard du sénat la parole
à monsieur le premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
vous avez cité le président de la
république dans son discours ougrée vous
auriez pu aussi même si c'est moins
prestigieux site et le premier ministre
à l'occasion du discours que j'ai
prononcé pour la première fois au sénat
je reconnais que ça a moins de prestige
mais mais vous mais vous reconnaîtrez
aussi madame la sénatrice que à
l'occasion de son discours j'avais
indiqués mon attachement bicamérisme le
rôle essentiel dans une démocratie de ce
dialogue permanent entre deux assemblées
qui tirent leur légitimité
deux modes de désignation différentes
temporalités différentes est un élément
constitutif constitutif de notre
équilibre démocratique et j'observe que
ce n'est pas propre au génie français
même s'il est considérable puisque dans
toutes les démocraties c'est ce dialogue
qui permet une forme de sagesse et d'
équilibre donc je n'ai aucun problème
madame la sénatrice à dire aujourd'hui
comme je les ai toujours dit que j'étais
attaché et au bicamérisme et au sénat et
j'observe que et j'observe madame la
sénatrice que dire ceci ne doit pas je
pense que vous pourrez le reconnaître
avec moi nous exonérer d'une réflexion
sur le bon fonctionnement du bicamérisme
sur la bonne désignation de ceux qui
siègent dans ces deux instances sûr mais
enfin bien entendu vous avez cité le
mouvement des gilet jaune reconnaissait
avec moi que dans la très grande masse
de revendications qui sont exprimés dans
leur très grande diversité
il y a aussi des questionnements pas
forcément sur l'existence de telles ou
telles assemblées mais sur la capacité
de telle ou telle assemblée a
correctement représenté la population
française je ne dis pas madame la
sénatrice
je ne dis pas madame la sénatrice que
c'est les seules revendications mais
nous pouvons je crois reconnaître que
ces questions sont posées âme dans une
démocratie comme la nôtre
le président de la république dans le
débat qu'il a engagées a ouvert un
chapitre sur la démocratie et la
citoyenneté
posons des questions dans la démocratie
et la citoyenneté sur la participation
de nos concitoyens la prise de décision
que ce soit d'ailleurs au niveau local
ou au niveau national sur la
représentation de nos concitoyens sur le
fonctionnement de nos institutions
sur ce besoin de participation de nos
concitoyens il a souhaité faire en sorte
que le débat soit ouvert
le président du sénat a choisi à
l'occasion d'une conférence de presse
qui se tenait je crois ce matin monsieur
le président d'indiquer c'est lui
appartenait l'attachement rappelé par le
président de la république au
bicamérisme il n'y a pas de sujet là
dessus en revanche je serai toujours
ouverts à cette discussion qui est une
discussion qui doit être continu dans le
temps pour faire en sorte que nos
institutions fonctionnent mieux que
notre bicamérisme fonctionne mieux que
nos citoyens soient toujours convaincu
qu'il fonctionne comme il devrait
fonctionner c'est ça le sens du débat et
je crois que ce sont des questions très
raisonnable et qui intéressent nos
concitoyens
voilà me jourdain
j'entends votre réponse monsieur le
premier ministre nous sommes d'accord
sur le fait qu'il faille mener une
réflexion je rappelle d'ailleurs qu'elle
avait commencé dans les assemblées avant
de se dérouler sur les ronds-points et
qu'à aucun moment le sénat ne s'était
montré hostile à cette réflexion
mais puisque nous sommes en temps de
grands débats je vais pouvoir faire
aussi
si vous permettez quelques observations
d'abord pour rappeler qu'avant tout le
président de la république au terme de
notre constitution
il est garant garant des institutions et
sans doute devra-t-il résister à la
tentation de jeter ses institutions en
pâture ou mécontentement de la
population pour précisément faire
changer d'objets à se mettre lentement
je rajouterai aussi que le président de
la république semble finalement beaucoup
s'inspirer du sénat désormais ces temps
derniers
j'en prendrai quelques exemples
lorsqu'il évoque le travail sur le
statut de l'élu lors de sa réunion
devant les maires de l'heure il parle du
rapport de nos collègues bockel dardoup
lorsqu'il évoque l'évolution de la loi
notre le président la république parle
de la proposition de loi pas retailleau
d'arnaud lorsqu'il évoque l'adaptation
locale de la limitation de vitesse à 80
km/heure il parle du rapport de nos
collègues raison du lien fichet
lorsqu'il évoque les objectifs annuels
en matière d'immigration dans sa lettre
aux français
le président de la république par de
l'amendement récent de notre collègue
roger karoutchi
lorsqu'il veut prendre des mesures
contre les casseurs concluant le
président légalement longue reprend la
proposition de loi du président
retailleau avant de songer à transformer
le sénat peut-être l'exécutif près tulle
songer à transformer son regard sur le
sénat nous ne sommes pas qu un
contre-pouvoir encombrants nous sommes
aussi et avant tout la voix des
territoires de france
merci la parole est à notre collègue
brigitte micouleau pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances monsieur le
ministre
depuis maintenant deux mois en marge des
manifestations des gilet jaune un
certain nombre de centres villes de
notre pays sont chaque samedi le théâtre
de violences et d'affrontements
inacceptable on ne compte plus les
commerçants artisans professions
libérales qui ont vu leurs locaux
attaquent et dégradés ou pillées quant à
ceux qui ont la chance d'échapper à ce
déchaînement gratuit de haine ils vivent
dans l'angoissé dès samedi à venir et
concepts de semaine en semaine
la mort dans l'âme le déclin de leurs
activités
craignant pour leur sécurité les clients
délaissent un effet massivement les
centres-villes chiffre d'affaires en
baisse de plus de 40% chômage technique
licenciement constitue aujourd'hui le
lot quotidien de nos commerçants
artisans restaurateurs hôteliers
l'avenir si rien ne change si rien n'est
fait pour les soutenir
une très probable explosion du nombre de
dépôts de bilan
or monsieur le ministre ces commerçants
et ses artisans jouent un rôle
économique mais aussi sociale plusieurs
municipalités consciente qu'il ne peut
exister de centre ville sans commerces
vont prendre des mesures d'urgence c'est
le cas de toulouse où un conseil
municipal exceptionnel examinera un plan
de dead de plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros
mais les communes ne peuvent pas tous
les maires prennent leur responsabilité
l'état doit également prendre les
siennes
plusieurs propositions d'être
individualisé seront demandés notamment
l'exonération non le saint et non le
simple report des charges sociales
patronales pour les mois de décembre et
de janvier de l'acf ainsi que le report
de la mise en application de la révision
des valeurs locatives commercial
monsieur le ministre
entendez-vous le désespoir des
commerçants et artisans des centres
villes comptez vous
leur venir en aide c'est urgent pour
vous répondre
la parole est aux ministres de
l'économie et des finances monsieur
bruno le maire mais madame la sénatrice
micouleau je partage totalement ce que
vous venez de dire j'ai l'occasion il ya
plus d'un mois de dire que ces violences
ces dégradations de commerces de
magasins
ces pillages était inacceptable et
qu'ils avaient un impact catastrophique
sur notre économie
je maintiens ces termes la violence et
dégradations
les pillages les menaces contre des
commerçants sont inacceptables et ont un
impact catastrophique sur notre économie
est toujours sur les plus petits
commerces surtout ceux qui ont des
commerces de centre ville qui ne peuvent
plus exercer librement leurs activités
c'est un impact également sur les
grandes surfaces qui ont du mal à
s'approvisionner
ça a eu un impact considérable sur la
restauration sur l'hôtellerie dans une
période de fêtes qui est normalement une
période le chiffre d'affaires est élevé
seuls un impact très important dans des
secteurs très spécifiques
le jouet l'alimentation l'habillement
nous allons faire le bilan des soldes
d'ici quelques jours pour voir l'impact
concret que cela et je vous confirme que
nous avons mis en place la cellule
d'urgence au ministère de l'économie et
des finances nous y travaillons avec
muriel pénicaud
la ministre du travail pour que nous
puissions avoir cet allègement de
charges pour ceux qui ont été le plus
touché nous restons en permanence ouvert
au dialogue avec les représentants des
commerçants et des artisans
je vous confirme également que nous
avons sollicité les assureurs pour
qu'ils répondent le plus rapidement
possible aux difficultés de ses
commerçants et puis nous sommes en train
de faire un bilan précis de l'évaluation
de l'impact économique du mouvement en
cours et des violences auxquelles elles
ont donné lieu pour que nous puissions
mesurer précisément l'impact de ce
mouvement sur la croissance française et
sur notre économie
en tout cas ma porte comme celle de miel
pénicaud reste ouverte en permanence aux
parlementaires qui le souhaitent aux
représentants des commerçants des
artisans de toutes les activités
économiques pour que nous travaillons
ensemble aux solutions
les plus efficaces possibles merci je
voudrais saluer dans cet hémicycle
madame françoise ramon notre nouvelle
collègue sénatrice d'eure-et-loir depuis
le 2 janvier
[Applaudissements]
prochaine question d'actualité le mardi
22 janvier
je vais suspendre la séance et sera
reprise à 16h15 pour le débat sur le
retrait britannique de l'union
européenne en vieux français briques
site
la séance est suspendue pour 10 minutes
et voilà pour ces questions d'actualité
du sénat au gouvernement tient ont été
marqués par le grand débat national et
notamment par la réforme des
institutions la sénatrice les
républicains muriel jourda a interrogé
le gouvernement sur la remise en
question du rôle du sénat notamment dans
la lettre aux français d'emmanuel macro
edouard philippe
le premier ministre lui a répondu en
disant qu'il était toujours très attaché
au bicamérisme dans les institutions
mais il a affirmé qu' il pouvait être
bond d'engager une réflexion sur la
bonne désignation des membres du
parlement et sur la participation des
citoyens à la fabrication de la loi
globalement dans ce grand débat national
les sénateurs souhaitent que qu'il y ait
une nouvelle étape dans la
décentralisation et que ce grand débat
se conclut par une grande conférence
sociale et territoriale pour redonner la
parole aux partenaires sociaux et aux
élus locaux
edouard philippe le premier ministre a
indiqué qu'il était plutôt favorable que
c'était une bonne proposition mais qu'il
souhaitait que les élus locaux
participent d'abord à cette grande
consultation
et puis autre moment fort dans cette
séance la question de la sénatrice
communiste
esther benbassa sur les violences
policières pendant les manifestations
gilet jaune elle a parlé de gazage de
respect de répression disproportionnée
sous les huées de la droite sénatoriale
le secrétaire d'état alors en une aise
secrétaire d'état au ministère de
l'intérieur à lui défendu les policiers
et l'usa je cite cadre et du flash ball
qui est fait face à des manifestants qui
je cite cherche parfois à lyncher et à
tuer les policiers
voilà pour les temps forts de cette
séance de questions d'actualité merci
beaucoup alexandre pour vos explications
on va continuer à d'analyser les temps
forts de cet ac ans avec mon invité
aujourd'hui nadia salut bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté l'invitation de puis
mixez la sénatrice centriste de la nier
on va parler évidemment de ce grand
débat mais aussi de l'avenir du sénat et
du cesa peut-être puisque gérard larcher
l'a rappelé ce matin n'y aura pas de
fusion pourtant et c'est là fait
toujours partie et bien des
interrogations sur cette réforme
institutionnelle on va aller venir un à
dire sollogoub dans un ensemble si vous
voulez bien on retourne salle des
conférences puisque la ministre des
affaires européennes nathalie l'oiseau
est au micro de talent fera nuit
et oui nathalie l'oiseau nous allons
parler ensemble de ce break site le
break si dur est il pour vous
aujourd'hui inévitable nous sommes et
bien à la veille à quelques minutes de
ce débat qui va avoir lieu au sénat sur
ce sujet nous sommes dans une période
d'incertitude
les européens ont négocié et conclu avec
le gouvernement britannique un accord de
retrait qui permet une séparation
raisonnable sens et ordonnée entre
l'europe et le royaume uni cet accord de
votre est la première mini britannique
l'a soumis à la ratification de la
chambre des communes
et elle a essuyé un échec est ce que ça
veut dire que cet accord de retrait est
totalement mort nous ne le pensons pas
aujourd'hui a pas 36 solutions il y en a
trois soit on veut à l'accord de retrait
on veut un retrait ordonné et c'est cet
accord qui a été négocié qui ne compte
pas réouvrir soit on est prêt à ce qu'il
n'y ait pas de briques site ça c'est aux
britanniques de le dire et nous la porte
reste ouverte à me remake soit il c'est
un retrait brutal sans accord et c'est
de moins en moins improbable
c'est la raison pour laquelle ali modu
nourrit ministre aujourd'hui absolument
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
préparons un 12e féminisme peut-être ça
vous avez l'impression que c'est de plus
en plus probable écoutez c'est aux
britanniques de déterminer mais en tout
cas c'est à nous responsables politiques
d'être prêt pour tous les scénarios
notamment en cas d'absence d'accord nous
voulons défendre les intérêts des
citoyens français des britanniques qui
réside sur notre sol parce qu'ils sont
les bienvenus les intérêts de nos
entreprises c'est ce que nous faisons
avec ce projet de loi qui je l'espère
sera adoptée tout à l'heure qui
permettra l'adoption définitive qui
habite le gouvernement à légiférer par
ordonnances exactement et à cinq
ordonnances qui sont en cours de
préparation elles sont même prêtes pour
dire les choses
la première sera présenté au conseil des
ministres dès la semaine prochaine si le
projet doit être adopté
donc nous allons vite nous serons prêts
nous avons mis des moyens de côtes et
des moyens humains des moyens financiers
pour faire en sorte que
on puisse continuer à circuler de part
et d'autre de la manche et que de notre
côté
la fluidité du trafic sera assuré oui
effectivement parce que le break ce
titre les breaks si dur ce sont des
problèmes très concrets oui des
problèmes pour les douanes des problèmes
pour les ports des primes pour les
aéroports pour l'industrie aéronautique
aussi est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
quelques uns des exemples de ces
problèmes que cela peut poser alors s'il
n'y a pas d'accord ça cela suppose que
nous rétablissions des contrôles
douaniers des contrôles réglementaires
pour les personnes et pour les
marchandises qui arrivent du royaume uni
pour cela il faut donc davantage de
policiers davantage de douaniers
davantage de vétérinaire et ils sont
recrutés ils sont en train d'être formés
ce que vous nous voulons c'est que les
contrôles aille vite pour ne pas
embouteiller la circulation donc il faut
des aires de stationnement là dessus des
autorisations sont demandés des
infrastructures temporaires seront
construites pour être prêt au 30 mars
bien merci beaucoup nathalie loisir
d'avoir répondu à mes questions alors
qu'effectivement je vous le disais il va
y avoir un débat qui va se tenir sur ce
sujet au sénat d'ici une dizaine de
minutes
merci à vous attend pour cette réaction
directe nadia salomé et sur notre
plateau sénatrice centriste de la nièvre
ya une réelle menace qui pèse
aujourd'hui sur le sénat le fait que ça
soit évoqué le rôle de cette institution
dans le grand débat on a appris et bien
que cette question était sur la table
dans la lettre d' emmanuel macron oui
alors évidemment c'est une inquiétude en
ce qui concerne la représentation le
fonctionnement de la démocratie en
france
j'ai du mal moi même à imaginer que l'on
puisse remettre en cause le bicamérisme
mais probablement que le sénat a un rôle
qui est mal compris et peut-être de ces
gens qui sont arrivés au bout de leur
colère et qui finalement trouvé une
façon ultime de manifester en essayant
de bloquer la france pour se faire
entendre
d'après ce que j'entends le sénat est
très mal compris et les gens ne
retiennent qu'une chose c'est que les
sénateurs ce sont des gens qui ont
d'énormes facilité et qui finalement
n'ont pas une grande utilité
alors je me dis que peut-être en termes
de communication c'est vrai qu'ils sont
peut-être abreuver bien sûr je parle pas
public sénat ils sont abreuvés de
reportages ont lors des bals des
scandales qui moi même
mes pattes parce que je ne vois même pas
comment on peut arriver à non se parler
montard isme c'est ce que vous dites oui
voilà c'est ça et par contre cette
question institutionnelle doit être
écarté du grand débat alors il faut que
les gens puissent s'exprimer dans le
grand débat par contre il ya quelque
chose qui est enfin le grand débat
lui-même n'arrive que parce qu'il ya un
problème avec les institutions parce que
théoriquement les gens devraient pas
avoir besoin d'être sur un rond point
d'avoir un gilet jaune
il devrait pouvoir s'adresser à leurs
députés et être entendu enfin je parle
de monsieur tout le monde à aller voir
son député que leur et députés puissent
librement et en dehors de toute
considération pour libérer quelque part
mon césar grassi direct parce qu'ils ont
le sentiment que la démocratie
représentative ne fonctionne pas bien
c'est exactement ça voilà si ça
fonctionnait normalement qu'ils avaient
l'impression est que ça remonte vraiment
ils n'auraient pas besoin d'avoir un ami
un grand débat n'est ni des excès de
cette nature après concernant le sénat
c'est vrai qu' il serait vraiment
intéressant que le grand public est
également des reportages sur ce qu'on
fait de bien au sénat à savoir faire
remonter la voix des territoires et de
nos collègues maires pour vraiment
introduire les amendements concret la
pédagogie autour du travail
parlementaire seulement retourner salle
des conférences
puisque tu aimes tran huy et vous êtes
avec bruno retailleau c'est le président
du groupe et l'air ici au sénat oui
bruno retailleau et bien tout d'abord
une question est bien sûr le bicamérisme
c'était un sujet sur lequel est
intervenu
gérard larcher ce matin il faut dire que
eh bien il a été passablement agacé par
la lettre français qui a été adressé par
emmanuel macron et qui parlait d'une
transformation du sénat voire une
suppression on peut l'imaginer qui
ouvrait le débat là dessus a bien sûr
peut-être que monsieur macron veut
encore plus de pouvoir peut-être que il
voudrait qu'il y ait aucun
contre-pouvoir en face de lui
on voit bien d'ailleurs sur la question
de monsieur benhadda mais on le voit sur
beaucoup beaucoup d'autres questions
d'ailleurs le gouvernement souvent vient
désormais piocher des bonnes idées dont
il a besoin par exemple sur contre les
violences et et est beaucoup beaucoup
d'autres idées aussi d'autres
propositions d'armes a dit en tout cas
ça voilà je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
démocratie ce n'est pas seulement
suffrage universel c'est la séparation
des pouvoirs et c'est le sénat qui porte
cette séparation des pouvoirs c'est le
sénat qui porte aussi une voie
différente la voix des territoires il
monsieur mac on ne peut pas dire j'ai
besoin des mères j'ai besoin des
territoires
vous ai goûté et en même temps vouloir
plus ou moins rabaisser le sénat qui est
l'ambassadeur et la voix des territoires
voix des territoires faut-il revenir
pour vous sur le non cumul c'est
important face à une certaine
déconnexion des élus on entend et bien
cette musique qui est en train de monter
et puis même emmanuel macron qui a dit
ne pas y être opposé pour les très
petites communes
bien sûr qu' il faut des élus qui soit
enracinée et là encore il ya un paradoxe
mais chez macron adore les paradoxes
il voudrait encore plus de
proportionnelle la proportionnelle c'est
quoi ces données la main aux partis
politiques de faire élire de faire élire
des gens qui sont des apparatchiks
voilà qui ne sont pas du tout implanté
dans lequel toi mais parce que ils ont
été désignés par leurs partis politiques
et bien mis en place dans des listes
très très haut dans des listes ils se
font élire grâce si j'ose dire à ces
investitures là c'est la négation du
lien entre l'homme le peuple et puis en
même temps le territoire va avoir une
espèce une expérience locale et ensuite
devenir parlementaire et ne plus avoir
un exécuté mais aujourd'hui mais vous
verrez on l'a bien vu sur la fin sur
cette crise cette crise et territoires
cette déconnexion et on le voit avec un
certain nombre de lits aujourd'hui la
force du sénat par exemple c'est que
pour la plupart nous sommes des élus
ancré dans les territoires nous avons
été maire président département
président de région et c'est ça qui est
important mais qu'est ce que veulent les
français ils veulent que les élus les
écouter comporter préoccupations du
terrain jusqu'à paris voilà une fois
qu'on sera devenu des élus or seuls
croyez moi la crise de la démocratie
elle s'aggravera fait référence la
commission denquête benalla votre
réaction à la garde à vue d'alexandre
benalla dans le volet des passeports
diplomatiques certains ne sont guère
étonnés après les révélations qu'il y
avait hier du directeur de cabinet
patrick strzoda voilà une belle
illustration de la nécessité du
bicamérisme c'est à dire d'avoir bien
sûr l'assemblée nationale et puis une
autre assemblée qui s'appelle le sénat
parce que l'assemblée nationale disait
non non non non il n'y a rien à faire il
ya rien à voir
si la justice s'intéresse au cas de
monsieur bénard c'est bien que tout ça
n'était pas anodin donc nous avons eu
raison de persister d'essayer de
connaître les dysfonctionnements au plus
haut niveau de l'état
donc cette affaire banana elle justifie
le bicamérisme la présence du sénat
parce qu'on voit bien que lorsque les
institutions sont d'un seul côté
lorsque si demain on avait des
institutions avec tous les pleins
pouvoirs au président de république dans
les mains d'un seul homme et bien à ce
moment là nos institutions fonctionnent
mal et je pense que tous ceux qui sont
attachés à la démocratie sont aussi
attachés à cet équilibre des pouvoirs
une toute dernière question d'actualité
c'est d'ailleurs l'un des sujets qui a
ouvert la séance tout à l'heure la
question des violences policières
le défenseur des droits demande la
suspension des lanceurs de balles de
défense
de nombreux manifestants ont été blessés
est ce que vous êtes
de son avis moi je veux rappeler qu'il y
à des policiers qui ont failli être
gâchée je veux rappeler et je me
souviens très bien les images en plein
d'attentes à islamique
je me souviens ces images où les
français embrasse les policiers qui nous
protège donc voilà je pense que la
violence elle était du côté d'un certain
nombre de délinquants de casseurs qui
est ainsi retombé en quête dans une
démocratie
tout doit être sur la table mais je fais
confiance d'abord aux forces de l'ordre
et attention un jour viendra où quand
ils ne pourront plus du tout agir pour
se protéger mais si surtout pour
protéger la république en ce jour
viendra qu'ils déposeront leurs casques
qu'ils déposeront leurs boucliers qui
protégera les institutions qui protégera
la république donc plutôt que de lancer
la pierre si j'ose dire aux forces de
l'ordre qui est des enquêtes très bien
elles se poursuivent l'igpn etc
faisons attention à ne pas des tracks
est là encore nos institutions et à ne
pas dévaluer ceux qui ont pour mission
de protéger les français de protéger la
république française il ya merci
beaucoup bruno retailleau prend votre
réaction
merci à vous faire agir les propos des
collections c'est ce qu'on reproche
aussi des parlementaires avec le terrain
alors oui justement je n'adhère
absolument à ce que vient de dire
monsieur retailleau bon en ce qui
concerne les élections c'est vrai que la
proportionnelle moi je ne suis pas
fameuse
je suis pas favorable parce qu'il faut
pas qu'on soit tous des apparatchiks en
effet de la politique mais par contre je
pense que pour simplifier il faut
vraiment imaginer qu'au sénat nous
sommes une assemblée de mer - juste il
ya 18 mois j'étais maire d'une commune
de 1500 habitants
voilà c'est tout et après je suis passé
directement sénat
pour parer porter cette voie là
justement juste d'un élu de terrain et
peut-être qu'on voit les choses
autrement et c'est pour ça que j'ai du
mal à faire la connexion
quand je vois le président de la
république qui passent sept heures avec
des élus de terrain justement ça vaille
pu être moi hier à dire je vous écoute
je vous parle je vous entends et je suis
là même au sénat alors c'est une très
bonne nouvelle si il accepte de reparler
au maire de rediscuter de entamer un
nouveau dialogue parce que du coup il va
refaire pareil avec les sénateurs parce
que nous sommes les mêmes nous sommes
les mêmes dont vous parlez cela a permis
au chef de l'état de lancer le grand
débat national on sait que il mise
beaucoup sur les élus locaux je
proposais d' écouter et voir le film qui
a été interpellé sur cette question
c'était il ya quelques instants c'est en
ses côtés un certain nombre de questions
ont été posées beaucoup 35 ou 36 je
crois de directement par le président de
la république dans sa lettre qu'il a
adressée aux français en répondant à ces
questions en s'exprimant sur ces sujets
les français vous nous donner un certain
nombre d'indications
il appartiendra ensuite au gouvernement
au parlement à l'ensemble de ceux qui
concourent au débat public d'en faire
leur miel de s'en inspirer dans la
réponse aux questions profondes et
anciennes qui taraude notre société
c'est dans cet esprit que nous nous
engageons et vous évoquez la question la
proposition qui a été formulée par
certaines organisations syndicales pas
toutes mais certaines qui était
d'ailleurs reprise par certaines
associations d'élus d'organiser au terme
de l'exercice une grande conférence
territoriale et sociale qui permettrait
à l'ensemble des acteurs en question
d'échanger sur ce qui ressort du grand
débat et de le transformer le cas
échéant en propositions de solutions
c'est une bonne proposition c'est que ça
que le gouvernement compte faire de
cette grande consultation de ce grand
débat c'est ce qui est le plus important
selon vous certains m'ont dit
bien que ne voyait pas la finalité de
cette grande consultation
moi j'ai très peur que la finalité c'est
avec une gigantesque frustration parce
que les gens sont tellement dans la
sincérité il faut se mettre à la place
des gens qui prennent toute une soirée
pour écrire une longue lettre avec des
détails avec des choses précises mais
qui peut traiter ça de façon
individuelle et personnalisée je vois
vraiment pas du tout alors si tout ça
tombe dans un espèce de magma et que ces
traités de façon globale c'est bien ça
va être extrêmement frustrant pour les
gens je vois pas du tout la sortie
autant j'ai trouvé admirable la réaction
des maires en période de tension un
moment donné on savait pas comment s'en
sortir samedi presque spontanément ils
ont dit venez dans vos mairies on ouvre
la porte vous avez un endroit où aller
venez on va parler ça c'était formidable
mme harman ont décidé de formaliser sa
en faisant croire aux gens qu'on va
individuellement prendre en compte leurs
propositions leurs doléances
enfin je trouve que ces mensonges et
voilà on va continuer à cet entretien
nadia salon retourne une dernière fois
salle des conférences avec vous autres
amis puisque vous êtes avec le sénateur
la république en marche de paris et
julien bargeton il a interpellé le
gouvernement sur la question aussi des
violences à l'encontre des journalistes
oui eh bien tout d'abord julien bargeton
je vais vous interroger sur le grand
débat il avait mal commencé la semaine
dernière avec notamment le départ de
chantal jouanno il est un petit peu
mieux continuer pour vous avec un
notamment et bien la prestation on peut
en parler cette façon là d' emmanuel
macron devant les maires dans l'eure les
mêmes macron à montrer finalement qu'il
était à l'écouté des territoires les
maires se sont les ambassadeurs de la
république
il les a écoutés il les a respectés il
leur a répondu longuement et on a vu les
qualités dont il sait faire preuve donc
effectivement il a engagé le débat de
bonne façon et on voit que la plateforme
a ouverte il y a déjà plusieurs
centaines de réunions prévues en
quelques jours donc déjà plusieurs
centaines de réunions qui sont prévues
c'est un moment inédit dans notre
histoire est unique par rapport au monde
aucun autre pays en europe ou en france
ne se livre à cet exercice démocratique
moi j'appelle tout le monde à participer
je suis déçu de voir
certaines oppositions pas tout un qui
refusent d'y participer
quoi de plus en plus les oppositions qui
acceptent le dis parce que je sens que
je dis à ta main mouvement je me réjouis
et je me réjouis d'un retournement de
certaines oppositions à part la france
est soumise mais qui se disent que
finalement la ce débat il est utile il
va être pertinent et il va apporter des
choses pour faire bouger la france et
c'est ce que nous attendons tous je
crois vraiment qu'il faut souligner ce
caractère risqué puisque quand vous vous
posez des questions et bien vous prenez
des risques mais vraiment inédit dans
notre histoire et j'en attends des
fruits oui effectivement vous l'avez dit
inédit est risqué et comporte encore de
nombreux floues notamment comment est ce
qu'on va faire et bien la synthèse de
tout ce qui va sortir de ce grand débat
est également amené ainsi question des
garants qui demeure on ne connaît pas
encore tous la question des de la
synthèse est importante et c'est
pourquoi il fallait mettre des thèmes ça
parfois été critiqué de mettre 4 4
thèmes et qui sont très larges dons qui
permettent d'ouvrir les débats et puis
35 questions posées par le président de
la république mais qui sont là aussi
assez large assez ouverte pour permettre
un débat très vaste et cela facilitera
aussi ce travail de synthèse et de
remonter parce qu'il ya quand même un
cadre certes sous plein parce que la
fiscalité de pouvoir d'achat on voit
bien que ça peut permettre de parler
tout mais qui permettront quand même de
classer les réponses et ensuite de les
traiter
moi je veux être confiant ne concluons
pas le débat avant même qu'il ne se
déroule bien merci beaucoup julien
bargeton pour votre réaction
merci à vous et à vous lancer quand même
un appel aux français à participer à se
saisir de cette opportunité c'est quand
même une consultation inédite même si
elle est risquée que lance le chef de
l'état alors très bien d'accord on y
croit par contre moi j'ai du mal à
comprendre parce qu'on dit aux gens
maintenant on va vous écoutez exprimez
vous et paradoxalement et parallèlement
moi je suis dans un département qui en
déprises démographique
donc on sait très bien que la réforme
constitutionnelle qui s'annonce va nous
faire perdre de la représentation
parlementaire actuellement nous sommes
deux députés de sénateurs dont quatre
parlementaires dans la nièvre le projet
c'est de passer à deux donc nous on perd
pas 30% de représentation parlementaire
on perd 50% de représentation
parlementaire dont comment on peut dire
dans le même temps aux gens on va vous
écouter encore plus venez vous écrire
nous écrit on est là pour vous mais à
partir de
demain matin vous serez deux fois moins
représentés mais ce sera mieux comme ça
voilà il ya quand même quelque chose que
j'ai du mal à comprendre ou bien merci à
vous et nadia salah merci d'être venu
sur le plateau de public sénat on voit
retourner ça des conférences pour
écouter jean pierre sueur sénateur
socialiste du loiret il était au micro
le talent fera ni ce texte il ya
quelques instants écoutez c'est une
décision de la justice donc la justice
fait son enquête elle fait son travail
et elle même monsieur ben alla en garde
à vue
je n'ai aucun commentaire à faire j'ai
fait parce que s'ils commentaires non
pas sur la garde à vue mais sur le fait
que patrick strzoda a parlé devant la
commission denquête de falsification
faite par alexandre benalla pour obtenir
un passeport de service et bien sur
cette question là je peux vous répondre
puisque il s'agit de notre commission
denquête et c'est un fait qui est
maintenant avérée en tout cas les
déclarations de monsieur strzoda et très
affirmatif m montre qu il y a eu de très
grands dysfonctionnements et hier nous
en avons découvert de nouveaux nous
allons de contradictions en
contradictions de découverte en
découverte
et c'est vrai que il avait quatre
passeports plus le sien je suppose c'est
un collectionneur de passe par je
rappelle qu'il y a un passeport
diplomatique qui lui a été délivré le
jour même ou le lendemain où il n'avait
plus aucune fonction
et oui en matière d'organisation de
voyages les 24 mai après avoir justement
et bien et le mal au ministère lui a
délivré ce qui est tout à fait étrange
dans le tas de coordination est alors
ensuite il en a fait part je crois au
service du protocole qui n'a pas réagi
de les séries du protocole de l'elysée
d'autre part eu pour ce qui est du
passeport de service de l'un des deux
passeports de service il en avait un
autre avant eh bien il est avéré
maintenant puisque monsieur strzoda la
halle a déclaré sous serment
qu'ils la quittent va on va entendre
monsieur bénard on va l'entendre qu'il
aurait qu'il a fait à un papier au nom
du chef de cabinet le chef de file du
courant
voilà pour un cette réaction de
jean-pierre sueur après la mise la garde
à vue d'alexandre benalla confirmée par
le parquet de paris avant de se quitter
on retourne dans l'hémicycle où nous
attend alexandre poussard puisque lé
sénateur s'empare du sujet du breakbeat
cet après midi oui les finisseurs vont
débattre du bric site pendant à peu près
une heure et demie et puis après ils
vont examiner un projet de loi commun
dans sa version avec la version de
l'assemblée nationale un projet de loi
qui autorise le gouvernement à prendre
des ordonnances en urgence pour réagir
aux briques cité notamment réagir à un
break site sans accord à ce qu'on
appelle un odile pour répondre à des
questions concrètes notamment régler le
sort des britanniques qui vivent en
france et qui après le break site
n'auront plus la liberté de circulation
des citoyens ordinaires de l'union
européenne et puis ce sont aussi les
conséquences économiques du mexique qui
préoccupent les sénateurs avec un
chiffre un exemple en cas de brick site
sans accord le port de dunkerque devra
réaliser près de 25 millions d'euros
d'investissements en équipements pour
pouvoir fluidifier son trafic et
s'adapter au retour des contrôles
douaniers donc dans leur état d'esprit
les sénateurs ne se font pas d'illusions
il est peu probable qu'il y ait un
accord de sortie sur le break site et la
france doit s'y préparer
merci beaucoup alexandre pour toutes vos
précisions
c'est la fin de cette édition remercia
bon de l'avoir suivez vous pourrez
revoir à les temps forts de la science
sur notre site internet publicsenat.fr
très bonne suite à des programmes sur la
chaîne parlementaire
[Musique]